[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Brazzaville capitale de la République
congolaise vient d'être le théâtre de
graves incidents une manifestation
déclenchée au cours d'une grève générale
de protestation rapidement dégénéré et
c'est terminé par 200 glandes bagarre
les manifestants se sont heurtés aux
forces militaires congolaises qui
défendaient les abords de la prison où
le président Fulbert du loup avait fait
enfermer les leaders syndicaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cinq morts et 12 blessés témoignaient de
la violence des accrochages de même que
l'incendie de la prison ou les
manifestants libéraires les prisonniers
[Musique]
ce premier acte était suivi d'un second
une foule évaluée à 5000 personnes
assiégait le palais présidentiel
[Musique]
l'abbé fulbergulu finissait par résigner
ses fonctions et il abandonnait bientôt
le palais présidentiel après avoir
transmis ses pouvoirs à l'armée un
gouvernement provisoire devait être
installé au cours de la nuit suivante
dirigé par Monsieur Masamba débat ancien
président de l'Assemblée il comprend
cette titulaire et ses données trois
mois pour régler la succession du
président Youlou dans le respect des
accords internationaux intérieurs
[Musique]
événement sanglant à Saigo dans une
pagode une jeune fille s'est suicidé
après avoir tenté de se couper le bras à
l'aide d'une hachette suicide de
protestation contre le gouvernement du
président de godine qui persécute les
bouddhistes on sait que 3 moines et une
religieuse bouddhiste se sont au cours
de ces derniers temps brûlés vif pour la
même cause ces actes isolés préluaient à
des incidents beaucoup plus dramatiques
encore si dans les jours suivants plus
de 10000 bouddhistes se sont rassemblés
pour faire ensemble une grève de la fin
de 24 heures ce n'était là encore qu'un
témoignage de l'état d'esprit de la
population bouddhiste mais on sait que
depuis la loi martiale a été proclamée
au Vietnam que les pagodes ont été
occupés par l'armée
le président Diem a chargé les
militaires d'assurer sécurité et ordre
public contre les troubles formés par
l'organisation communiste du vietng dont
il accuse les donzes de faire le jeu des
heures graves pour le Sud Vietnam
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la flotte française vient d'être dotée
d'un porte hélicoptère premier bâtiment
de ce type en France à la fois porte
aéronef et croiseur anti-aériens la
résolu est également destinée à
remplacer sur toutes les mers du globe
le vieux Jeanne d'Arc comme croiseur
d'applications de l'École navale
il est équipé d'une piste d'un vol de
100 mètres et peut abriter 4
hélicoptères lourds du type Super Frelon
ces appareils seront utilisés pour la
détection et le torpillage des
sous-marins
[Musique]
au crépuscule du 24 août Paris a fêté le
19e anniversaire de sa libération le
cortège officiel a remonté la scène
cette grande rue de Paris sous les ponts
embrasés jusqu'à l'hôtel de ville où une
foule considérable s'était rassemblée
atteint les chars de Leclerc qui
rapportaient de la gare Montparnasse le
fanion du libérateur
c'est ce fanion qu'en présence de la
Maréchal Leclerc le ministre des Anciens
Combattants Monsieur Jean Santeny devait
remettre au président du conseil
municipal relique précieuse qui témoigne
de la journée historique ou Paris
retrouve à sa liberté et sa fierté
[Musique]
ce petit tour de devoir de vacances nous
a conduit d'abord à Pont-l'Évêque sur
Oise où se déroulait le championnat de
France de joute sur l'eau vieux sport
dans l'origine remonte à l'occupation
des troupes romaines qui avait pris goût
à ce jeu lors de leur campagne d'Égypte
depuis il n'a jamais cessé d'être
populaire
en dépit de son aspect violent l'ajoute
nautique est un sport chevaleresque et
le vainqueur comme au Moyen-Âge peut
s'enorgueillir non seulement d'avoir
rompu quelques lance mais encore d'avoir
démonté l'adversaire et laver son
honneur à grand dos
[Musique]
devoir de vacances une trentaine de
concurrences sur la plus belle plage
d'Europe une douzaine de nations
représentées c'est la Baule et son
concours international d'ouvrage de
sable notons que ce concours se déroule
pour la cinquième fois ce qui prouve que
l'on peut parfois bâtir sur le sable au
milieu de diverses Notre-Dame de Paris
Tour de Belém ou saint-paul-de-londres
le Palais Bourbon
œuvre d'un jeune espagnol obtient le
second prix et le petit français Alain
Bono sera classé premier pour son
bouddha d'une très belle facture et que
l'on s'est athée d'admirer avant que la
marée ne vienne tout effacer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la côte basque ne détrônera sans doute
pas demain Hawaii ni melbour nous prie
naissance ce sport magnifique qu'on
nomme le surfing et dont Biarritz abrite
le championnat d'Europe
une planche munie d'une dérive voilà
tout l'outillage ajoutez-y une bonne
pratique de la natation et des qualités
de courage et d'adresse et vous pouvez
être le champion des surfeurs il s'agit
de se rendre au large et de se laisser
alors porter au rivage sur la crête
d'une vague c'est tout mais on mesurera
la qualité du spectacle la qualité de
l'exploit
[Musique]
les images disent mieux que les mots la
beauté de ce sport implantés depuis peu
en France mais qui compte déjà des
centaines d'adeptes
[Musique]
c'est du côté de chez Dior que nous
sommes allés chercher la ligne de la
saison la collection créée par Marc
borne le retour au vrai tailleur
jupe veste et blouse souvent d'ailleurs
agrémenté d'un cache-né
jaquette appuyait et souvent étiré
boutonné oh jupe droite ou appli plat
notons une prédominance du style
chemisier
les manteaux parmi lesquels apparaissent
quelques somptueuses imperméables sont
dessinés sans ampleur excessive mais la
carrure le col et les manches se sont
développées épaule large et silhouette
droite telles sont les mots d'or
les robes possèdent des encolures
importantes montantes et la carrure est
accentuée
[Musique]
pour l'après midi pour le cocktail le
tailleur de dentelle fait son apparition
il fait bon ménage avec ses robes
droites de ligne simple à l'encolure
dégagée
[Musique]
la robe du soir impose le style de la
saison long fourreau de ligne sinueuse
dont le décolleté montant sur la gorge
mais échancrés dans le dos peut
s'accompagner de longue manches et
souvent d'un boléro orfèvré de broderie
et de cabochon voici le bel hiver du
côté de chez Dior
[Musique]